[Music]
we were talking with rashida Jones
not long ago wife your beautiful wife
lovely co-star rashida Jones and she
showed her high school yearbook photo
mm-hm and it was it's just such a great
way to sort of get an insight into what
someone was like back in the day and so
yes yes it is yes it is we have one that
we found we found your and and I thought
maybe you could just tell us a little
bit every day I'd walk you to school and
I would just be like you're welcome
fellas yeah you can tell here that hello
and I'm the lead singer for the go-go's
storm that morning thank you taken but
you know I I have a picture I have your
high school year but now you know no
one's found no I don't
[Applause]
that's yeah yeah that's that's what I
was trying the center part yeah do you
need to have a column in your back
pocket that was a big thing I gotta calm
in my bed you just and yes
surreptitiously like during the day just
feather it feather it and put it back in
now I would stab people jab we went but
I didn't really peak in high school I
was like I'm late bloomer and
I did not win any superlative but I did
come in third runner-up for most casual
in high school in high school most
casual casual which I don't know if it's
casual in manner or a dress but either
way I wanted it too much cuz I am third
runner-up okay yeah that hurts you
what about like moving on like what else
did you get voted besides most well when
I was in eighth grade I was voted
friendliest and then I blew it and I
became very casual you can be casual and
friendly well you did you ever win
anything like we never had people always
ask me I know if you had this stuff
idiot I was most humorous no I was not
I went to a big high school and they
didn't vote on things like that they're
just like get in here get the hell out
the pictures of like most likely to
succeed and it's always very the very
dated picture so it's like 80s with like
a giant cell phone and like money and
like they were like sure like how cool
rich people are gonna dress and it's
like a cell phones like this big we have
I'm curious I want to ask you about you
know for many years I can't remember how
many seasons you did before but you you
anchored a co-anchored Weekend Update
and that's a job where you have to be on
top of the news all the time now that
you're on Parks and Rec and doing movies
do you still follow the news
no the only do even know who won the
election I I know it went well I get is
from your monologue it's the only way I
get my news oh great yeah I learned oh
it's terrifying I didn't know half that
stuff I was saying yeah no we drink our
own urine
Oh terrible toll on against that I know
that I'm against drinking my own urine
that's where we differ
let's just agree to disagree
it'll never convince you I feel sorry
for any young person that gets their
news from this show be the most cute
stupid perspective on the world